Pascal is here the GP 104 has arrived on
the GTX 1080 graphics card that we have
here we've Benchmark this for frame
rates thermals power noise and more and
what we're looking at today is the GTX
1080 Founders Edition the main news here
just to sort of bring everyone up to
speed GPU 104 is the Pascal architecture
this is the first Pascal architecture
card shipping for consumers for the
gaming market and the big change here is
that it's got a refined or a brand new
actually processing so it's running a 16
nanometer finfet process as opposed to
Maxwell's 28 nanom planer process and
that has some inherent power efficiency
and performance for wat gains that will
hopefully be reflected in our test that
we're showing you today before diving
into all of this I want to just sort of
let everyone know we've got a 9,000 word
article review of this card written on
the website hit the link in the
description below for the full article
because we can't go into all the same
detail in a video that we can in that
article and the article includes things
like more depth on AC is comput more
depth on SR architecture more depth on
memory subsystem things like that so
you'll find that link below but let's
dive into this thing look at some of the
testing data and specs the GTX 1080 is
priced at $700 currently for the
founders Edition which is equivalent to
the previous reference nomenclature see
our previous video for that MSRP for
board Partners is $600 so we'll see a
range of 600 and higher and the cards
ship on May 27th for the founders
Edition this is the specs table for all
the recent Nvidia video cards shown on
the screen now on the far left is the
Tesla p100 accelerator card which runs
the GP100 cut version of big Pascal that
was the first Pascal architecture device
but was shipped with scientific tasks in
mind it was not a compute card the GTX
1080 debuts the GP 104 version of Pascal
and a lot of the architecture is similar
in terms of sort of top level ideas and
the process note is the same but SM
architecture is varied in some ways
compute preemption is similar in some
ways there's a couple differences though
that we'll talk about the GTX 1080 has
2560 CTIC cor split between four gpcs
and 20 SMS the reduced cores per SM mean
more dedicated resources per SM
partition so to speak SMS are broken
into two quote unquote partitions of
cores and schedulers and warps and
buffers and things like that and we'll
talk about that momentarily other than
the process shrink the most obvious
change to GP 104 for consumers is the
introduction of 8 GB of gddr5x memory
that X is new and important gddr5x vram
from Micron has an effective operating
frequency of 10 GHz on this particular
device and it's got a 256bit interface
again on this particular device it
offers a midep between the 40ish per
slower gddr5 and the future of hbm2 high
bandwidth memory of course shipped
originally on Fiji amd's card and hbm2
will be coming to Vega later and
hopefully to Nvidia sometime maybe in
the next year but it's got low yields
right now gddr5x operates at 10 GBS per
second per die on GP 104 and has the
potential to grow to 13 to 14 gbits per
second with micron's future advances and
gdr 5 for a reference operates at about
8 GBS per second versus the 13 to 14
maximum capacity that Micron is
targeting for
gddr5x the GTX 1080 runs at 1733 MHz
boosted with a GPU boost 3.0 update and
can overclock Beyond 2 GHz as you'll see
later it's got nine teraflops of fp32
compute at stock whereas the
gtx980ti has 5.63 teraflops and the GTX
1070 has 6.5 teraflops most notably the
GTX 1080 has a TDP of 180 watts and
requires only a single 8 Pin power
header which is a pretty big change as
well of course I know you all want to
see the benchmarks right away so we'll
start there starting with thermal noise
and then FPS and you can find all of our
testing methodology on the website in
the article if you're curious how we
conducted these tests for gaming we
tested openg GL directx11 12 and Vulcan
we also tested 1080 1440 and 4K
resolutions games include Doom ashes of
Singularity tals principal tumor the
division GTA V Shadow of Mordor Metro
last Light and more we will not show all
the charts here as that would be insane
so again article for those as many of
you know we used a thermal chamber
recently to validate our thermal testing
methodology and found it to be highly
accurate thanks to our ambient logging
actively with a thermal couple reader
here's our equilibrium chart as we call
it for ease the GTX 1080 operates at
57.5 Celsius under load and 7.96 CSI
idle comparatively that's roughly 49%
warmer than the fury X which is liquid
cooled at 36.3 n Celsius and is
effectively identical to the GTX 980ti
reference Edition the founders Edition
cooler is able to keep the more powerful
GTX 1080 at about the same temperature
as the gtx980 TI's reference cooler does
for the gm200 chip and then of course
we've got the hybrid card on here as
well from EVGA and that is just insane
but it's a much different design and
it's more expensive here's a look at
Thermals over time thermal torture
commences at the same 122 Mark for all
devices because we use a custom program
after adding ambient back in we would
see that The Thermals hit about 80
Celsius and stay there for these Nvidia
devices and especially the 1080 the fan
will adjust itself accordingly to
maintain this thermal level and that is
something we'll talk about with
throttling this next test is the new one
for us the purpose here is to run an
endurance test and generate a chart that
looks for throttling under tortured
scenarios we disable the Open Bench fans
to this end and just let the GPU try to
cool itself and create a worst case
scenario for it hoping to discover if it
would throttle the frequency against a
thermal barer somewhere that's what
we're looking to discover here unlike
the earlier charts this temperature is
represented as an absolute value not a
Delta you'll notice that over the 2hour
test period running dirt rally at
completely maxed settings all accounts
the GPU seemed to sit around 80 Celsius
and Peak occasionally and then also
dropped in frequency occasionally here
is a cropped in look at those dips where
you can see what what's causing the
drops and if you look closely you'll see
that it's basically the temperature
hitting about 82 Celsius causing the
frequency fluctuations which show a
range of about 60 MHz each time the GPU
diode hits 82 Celsius absolute
temperature and that can trigger a
slight latency increase or a slight
frame rate fluctuation at the exact
moment of the frequency drop but it is
basically imperceptible and not
something to really be concerned about
because overall we've seen this five
times over a period of 2 hours enough of
that let's talk power and noise then
games total system power consumption
this is not per card but for the whole
system offers a difference comparison
for the GTX 1080 Fe cards we see that
they said around 300 watts this is a bit
more power than the gtx980 required non
TI but a fair bit less than the gtx980ti
that's also shown here as for noise all
this methodology and the meters and
setup we used are defined in the article
pretty important to check that out if
you want to know more idle noise levels
are more or less imperceptibly varied
between all the cards tested after the
5minute GPU load period the R9 290x
pushes the loudest Auto DB output at
49.3 Dees and would be perceptible even
from within an enclosure the R9 Fury X
may only be 39.082097 decb but it's
still the one we've got produces that
high pitched pump wine that we wrote
about ages ago the MSI twin frozer card
keeps the lowest DB level at
38.379493
DB effectively identical no card
realistically hits the 100% fan speed
they tend to sit around 50% if they can
help it but the stats show the R9 290x
at 70 DB on its reference design the GTX
1080 at 57.2 DB and the 980 TI
noticeably louder at 63.4 DB the 980 at
59.5 2 DB the fury X and twin frozer
cards again run the quietest for
reference conversational speech is about
65 is maybe 70 DB depending on how
loudly you talk all right time to test
some games we're opening with doom which
we just tested this is an open GL game
not a Vulcan or DX game and it runs on
two different versions there's 4.3 that
it runs on for AMD that's something done
by ID software and 4.5 openg for NVIDIA
so keep that in mind uh let's jump into
this we already posted the full
Benchmark by the way for this game if
you want to learn more about it 4K shows
the GTX 1080 as being the only card
getting within throwing distance of 60
FPS one or two setting tweaks would push
the GTX 1080 into full 60 plus FPS
action the GTX 1080 Fe at stock clock
outperforms the stock clock GTX 980 TI
by 13.8% against the fury X Delta is
widened to 21.4% but that's still really
in the real world not that noticeable
the GTX 1080 is off to a good start
though and the value proposition is a
bit better against these similarly
priced devices 1440p shows a significant
performance lead for the 1080 planting
at 98.3 FPS and with the best low frame
times on our bench the GTX 1080 is the
most tightly timed card for frame
delivery that we've tested as of this
instance and against the predecessor GTX
non 980 non-ti performance performance
gains are a staggering 30% over again
the 980 non TI against the 98 TI however
the performance difference is again 133%
similar to the last one we looked at
here's the 1080p chart in this test it's
clear that we're bottlenecking somewhere
else in the system probably on our 593k
CPU and that CPU bind does mean that
we're seeing the 98 TI and 1080 push
effectively an identical performance
output either way either card would
enable close to 144 Herz gaming if an
appropriate CPU is paired with them we
tested a few new API games but ashes is
the most interesting as it's the most
reliable with the most data we ripped
the satellite Shot 2 Data from ashes
which shoves large batches down the pipe
and chokes components we have two sets
of data for Ashes to feature millisecond
latency between frames and it's
Improvement yield from dx12 and the hard
frame rate comparison chart between dx11
and dx12 what you're looking at right
now is the 1080p High comparison of dx12
and dx11 performance with ashes GTX 1080
holds a clear lead over everything when
using dx12
this is because of GP 104's clear
improvements and asynchronous compute
which I'll explain in a few minutes
notice that the fury X and 390x are both
choking on some sort of direct X11
optimization issue where they can't
circumvent a CPU hangup or other bottom
neck in the system hence they're
identical performance they're getting
bottlenecked and this is something which
nvidia's dx11 drivers are good at
working around looking at dx12
performance though AMD shows some of the
biggest raw gains from the new API and
that's great news for them as the
industry Trends toward dx12 and Vulcan
now look at the GTX 980 its dx11
performance ranked it high among the
cards but once we sort by dx12 it's
clear that the 980 is the loser on the
bench 4K High shows similar performance
changes as does 4K with crazy settings
the GTX 1080 has made obvious
improvements the dx12 optimization and
frame rate and here's a frame time chart
with 1080P and high lower is better here
it's measured in milliseconds notice
that amd's Bane is its dx11 frame
latency which creates the stuttering
scene in dx11 the 1080 has an absurdly
low 13.38 millisecond average frame time
which is good but that's not to take
away from the improvements made across
the board for AMD and Nvidia both with
their newest architectures here's the
percent change chart for latency the
fury X sees a 120% latency reduction the
390x sees a massive 76.9% latency
reduction both a reward of amd's
investment in async compute while the
older GM 204 Max architecture struggles
to stay positive GTX 1080 and GP 104
however combine Brute Force compute with
async improvements to generate a 48.6 5%
Jaun in dx12 which is massive news for
NVIDIA who struggled in the last
generation with dx12 so they're finally
gaining some serious ground here and
have become a real contender in the new
API space to see more dx12 and Vulcan
performance check the article we're
trying to keep this bit of it short cuz
it is pretty complex data let's look at
dx11 at 4K the GTX 108 holds nearly a
30% lead against both the GTX 98 TI and
the R9 Fury X the 1080 is the first
single GPU that is able to sustain our
GTA 5 4K Benchmark with all main
settings on very high and Ultra it
pushes 56 FPS which is well within the
acceptable range without many in-game
hiccups at 1080p the GTX 1080 pushes
into 125 FPS and leaves behind the 98 TI
on Fury X again both of which sit at
about 16% lower frame rates the fury X
drops its .1% low values below 60 FPS
but that's really not too bad here and
generally pushes less consistent frame
times than the 1080 now we're looking at
Black Ops 3 we've had to expand our
scale for these charts past 160 FPS
because the GTX 1080 crushes frame rates
at 22.3 FPS average for 1080 but if
you're buying this thing you really
aren't going to be playing on 1080 let's
all be honest again that the 200 is an
average with 1% lows those exceed 130
FPS and the GTX 1080 is exceptional in
its frame rate performance here and runs
tight frame times meaning consistent
latency between frame delivery and the's
R9 Fury X also performs very well in
Black Ops 3 and outperforms the 980ti
just barely assuming a reference 980ti
anyway and that's all we've really got
for uh for this test the fury X is still
about 24% behind the 1080 even at 1440p
and the 1080 is nearly at 144 Herz range
and would easily sustain such high frame
rates with a few settings tweaks if you
needed it as for 4K the card pushes 68
FPS average and holds a firm lead over
the fury X and its average frame rate
but a massive lead over the fury X's
0.1% low dips which this Fury X Card
seems to show its 4 GB limitation in
some of these 4K high setting scenarios
because the vram is just being tapped so
heavily this is a consistent issue in
some of the dx11 games with the fury X
though dx12 is somewhere AMD excels and
you'll see that in or you've already
seen that in some of the test results
for sake of time we're going to stop the
game Benchmark charts here if you want
to see more Link in the description
below you'll find Metro uh and a couple
of other dx11 12 and Vulcan analysis
items that you can look at but now we're
going to talk about overclocking
overclocking has changed thanks to GPU
boost 3.0 but not too much first of all
we have an interview with Tom Peterson
and Technical marketing director at
Nvidia that's live with this video you
can check that out for more depth on how
overclocking works the main thing here
first of all GP boost 3.0 enables a new
feature called scan OC what this does is
it plots a frequency voltage curve on
your particular GPU and it looks for
specific frequencies where voltage may
need to be peaked or lowered or whatever
to sustain a stable overclock that is an
automated tool you basically click scan
and it runs some sort of Burnin program
basically a reskinned firm Mark for
evga's precision and then that looks for
what your maximum potential overclock is
the reason this exists is because when
performing overclocking there's this
chance that you'll end up with a pretty
high and stable OC high frequency but
once you start throwing specific
applications or games into the mix maybe
The Witcher three triggers a specific
point of failure it's not triggered on
other games the only real solution is to
step down the OC or to create multiple
profiles for multiple games and that
just kind of sucks so scan OC bypasses
that that's the thing uh I was not able
to get it functioning properly for this
review it crashed incessantly but we did
get something together through the old
means and that was just by manually
sitting there and ocing it myself and I
have several sheets here of passes and
failures uh that I'm not going to read
all of them to you but the one that we
settled on was a pretty light OC in
terms of what I think this card's
capable of but it was the max that I
could get out of the founders Edition
cooler and that's because of some of the
thermal throttling we talked about
earlier so max OC I was Landing between
225 MHz and 250 MHz so I was Landing
between that range I maximally hit I
think it was 2080 MHz and it's not too
bad the memory clock I was hitting 5400
MHz I didn't try to push that higher you
probably could but I I pushed at 400 MHz
and kind of left it voltage I was
sitting at 1.031 volts and My OC was a
120% power Target so we're giving an
extra 20% to the TDP to the card uh 220
MHz OC to the core which produced that
20 25 2050 MHz output 400 to the memory
and then a 37% voltage increase which
really didn't push 37% extra volts to it
cuz we've talked about that in Maxell
it's the same here it doesn't really
always give it all that it's got or that
you ask for now in terms of FPS here's
the impact we got I'm reading off of
paper here because we just did this test
and interrupted the video to do it the
GTA 5 4K Benchmark sees an improvement
from 56 FPS stock frequency to 65 FPS
overclock that's a pretty big gain
that's a a full 9 FPS Mordor moves from
60.7 FPS stock to 6 5 oced at 4K not a
huge gain but not bad and then at 1440p
it moves from 106 to 113 FPS reasonable
Doom moves from 98 FPS stock at 1440 to
109 FPS OC pretty big gain actually a
bit over 10% I believe and then 51.7 FPS
stock to 59 FPS at 4K overclocked so
what this tells us is that first of all
the the headro for o is large for this
card uh it is only limited on the
founders Edition by the cooling
potential which we'll talk about very
shortly I have a pretty special feature
for that uh but that's the main
limitation it tells us that aib boards
the the addin boards from the aib
partners will be significantly better at
overclocking in terms of their cooling
potential now whether or not the Silicon
can handle it that's a different story
we have to really get more handson
samples to figure out exactly where the
sort of silicon lottery plays out with
this particular chip but that's all I
got for you with overclocking all right
this is the hard part I'm going to try
and condense all the pertinent
architecture information into just a few
minutes and we'll see how it goes we're
going to be talking about gpcs SMS the
memory subsystem and other items like
that if you want some of the visual
guides again link below for those let's
start with a block diagram this is GP
104 unlike GP 100 which is much
different in a couple of key ways the GP
104 GPU does not have in fact 15 billion
transistors and it also doesn't have six
gpcs with 10 SM each that's what GP
100's got GP 104 is shrunken down to
four gpcs with 20 total SMS in some ways
it can be thought of as a shrunken
Maxwell it's very similar in a couple of
key areas there are 20 tpcs for GP 104
and the total tmu count hits 160 which
is calculated simply by multiplying the
tmus per SM by the SM count so there's 8
tmus per SM * 20 equals 160 tmus like
gp1 100 GP 104 partitions its SMS into
two blocks of cores each with 64 Cuda
cores that's one 28 per SM partitioning
the cores into smaller clusters helps
allocate more dedicated resources to
these cores like warp schedulers that Q
threads dispatch units register files
cache and memory that get access
frequently things like that each SM has
its own 256 kilobyte register file a 96
KOB shared memory unit 48 kiloby L1
cache and 8 tmus that's again per SM
stepping up a level we zoom out and kind
of look at gpcs each GPC has its own
raster unit as well so that's four total
for GP 104 new to GP 104 is its
polymorph engine 4.0 which was
introduced on fmy each TBC has a
polymorph engine that executes specific
tasks mostly related to its Nvidia
simultaneous multiprojection tool that
was recently introduced smpp is used to
ensure multi-display surround display or
nonflat display output is Warped
according to its position relative to
the user so if you've got monitors sort
of on an angle towards you the polymorph
engine deals with all of that
translation now let's compress
asynchronous compute in a similar
fashion asynchronous compute paves the
way for leveraging low-level apis and
asynchronous command queing allows GP
resources to be allocated between
non-dependent tasks there are three
major changes to async compute in Pascal
from previous architectures and it
affects these items one overlapping
workloads two real-time workloads and
three compute preemption for gaming GPU
resources are often split into graphics
and compute segments eg a selection of
cores cache and other elements assigned
to Graphics while the remainder is
assigned to compute and the resources
are partitioned to for instance Ren Ing
and post-processing effects and it may
be the case that one of those
partitioned clusters say the cluster
that's handling rendering completes its
workload prior to its partner maybe
handling something else compute whatever
that compute allocation may still be
crunching a particularly complex problem
when the render allocation completes its
job leaving the units allocated to
rendering idle that's wasted resources
you don't want that you don't want to
leave those units idle async command
queing structures allow for more
resource adjustment on the Fly enabling
concurrent inflate jobs to all reach
completion this is called Dynamic load
balancing and allows workloads to scale
as resources become available or busy
maybe 50% of resources are allocated to
compute and the other 50% to rendering
something like that if one job completes
the other job can consume idle resources
in speed of completion and reduce
latency between frames in this image the
command push buffer stores triangle and
pixel data and halfway through working
on its latest draw call which you see on
the far right you'll notice that it's
stopped working on that draw call the
reason is because Pascal allows for
preemption request to arrive hit that
push buffer and basically demand
priority over other tasks and at that
point the push buffer pauses its
execution saves all the rasterized and
shaded pixel data frees itself sell for
use elsewhere and then can execute that
command later when the preemption is
done Pascal can perform pixel level
thread level and instruction level
compute preemption and that allows some
very low reaching changes to the the
data structure so that these things like
Time Warp for VR can be dropped in as
needed if something's really critical so
the user doesn't vomit from VR now jdr5x
introduces a lot of changes too and I'd
love to talk about it more but we're
going to keep that short and just talk
about memory compression very briefly
Nvidia has moved to its fourth
generation Delta color compression and
DCC functions by looking at all the
color data temporally which means
basically frame the frame and then
reduces colors losslessly into Delta
values so instead of fetching all the
color data from an absolute value DCC
can group as an example of the Blues and
the sky box of game together store a
neutral value that resides between them
all and then use that neutral sort of
mean to reach outward with Delta values
and then create the colors that are
needed later as as they are required
this compression approach reduces
bandwidth consumption by about 20% DCC
can do 8 to1 color compression maximally
but also offers 4:1 and the original
Maxwell 2:1 and more on that in the
article and so we come to the conclusion
so this thing is the GTX 1080 worth it
well first of all this one founded
Edition is $700 you should expect to see
cards hitting these 650 I would think
they technically they can go as 600 by
MSRP standards uh but we'll see 650 600
cards as these aib Partners start
shipping their devices in terms of
performance Nvidia has definitely
improved some of their dx12 Vulcan and
other API performance issues from the
past uh it's a good card it's performed
the best out of all the cards we've
tested and the 1080 has about a 30% lead
over the 980 this one and the fury X not
shown here now one thing to note this
1080 in some games it's well actually
almost all games it's about 133% ahead
of the 98 TI 98 TI was very powerful but
if you have one now I wouldn't I
wouldn't upgrade to this because why
133% is kind of like who cares uh so
it's got a 133% lead there if you have
something like a hybrid the EVGA hybrid
which I think is somewhere around 1200
megahertz boosted uh the Gap actually
shrinks considerably so you end up with
more of a 10% some games even lower
difference between the two so a lot of
the gains here I think for Pascal can be
chalked up to sort of the frequency
increase it's more than 1700 MHz when
it's running boosted now that is a
massive increase over this which I could
get this up to probably 1,400 1500
stable uh, 1500 for sure I was able to
hit before if you did that you'd be
pretty darn close with these two devices
but uh 98 TI hybrid is more expensive
1080 is better architecture better sort
of at the ground level it's got 8
gigabytes of memory which is actually
becoming relevant now and overall the
1080 is definitely the card to buy out
of the 9980 980 TI and 1080 in the
future uh Fury X is kind of a it's an
interestingly placed card it's not
something I would buy over the 1080
right now because the price is very
similar I think I've seen it like 650 in
some places versus 700 for this uh so
the only thing you really gain is the
lower thermals and hbm but we're seeing
that .1% frame time kind of hurt the
fury X in games where it's exceeding the
4 GB allocation on that card the GTX
1080 Founders Edition runs reasonably
cool but aibs will obviously outperform
that pretty easily Nvidia is trying to
Grant its reference cards longer staying
power by continuing to sell them through
EOL but I would still point you toward
the board partners for fiercer
competition that'll drive prices down
they'll pre- overclock the cards and the
1080 will be a good purchase at the top
end as the price drops down more towards
that 600 low end that they're listing
700's pretty steep I it's not unfair
it's just a lot of money and if you can
wait a couple months for the market to
stabilize and start pumping out these
cards then it's definitely a good weit
and you'll save some money get something
that runs cooler as well it's already an
easy choice though over the 98 and R9
Fury X both of which are priced
similarly and lower performing sometimes
133% for the 908 TI sometimes up to 30%
for the furyx so definitely an obvious
win there for the 1080 so thank you for
watching I know this was huge Link in
the description below for more
information patreon link postal video if
you want to help us out directly for
these efforts I'll see you all next time
oh
[Music]